um
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey here we are once again
friday night hopefully the audio is
working
yeah can everybody hear us because i've
been i've been having all kinds of
like [ __ ] problems today we got a
good one it's gonna uh it's the uh
columbine massacre i can't believe we
haven't got around to this
i've talked about this case before i
actually knew some people went to call
by
but uh i told you about that man yeah
talk about it
but um other than that
i'm uh still feeling kind of like [ __ ]
uh i'm better today than it was
yesterday
uh so but i'm still not like [ __ ] at
the top of my
my tom ross game
[Laughter]
yeah yeah which some people might like
that
[Laughter]
sometimes tom's just got to shut the
[ __ ] up
there's another shirt right there i will
wear that shirt with pride
sometimes tom just needs to shut the
[ __ ] up
that's not what i said sometimes [ __ ]
tom just gotta shut the [ __ ] up
yeah sometimes you've gotta yeah
although you do know about this case so
you do need to help you know
because this one's kind of like a
complicated one and i do kind of feel
like
as well there's a lot of um
misconceptions about this case like what
you know what caused it you know and
uh there's a lot of theories about it
it's like [ __ ] that came out about it
later on
this is before the [ __ ] second war
second part of the war broke out
i was living in [ __ ] past christian
mississippi
and partying a lot in the french quarter
down in new orleans
thank you dj maniac yeah he says
sometimes tom needs some advil too
yeah yeah he's been taking that thing
so i was hanging out the crystal down
the [ __ ] french quarter that and uh
[ __ ] pierre's uh the convent was a
private club where jerry springer's
[ __ ] hangout
yeah we've sold that story before yeah
one they wouldn't let marilyn manson
into
and uh just hanging out down there and
[ __ ] when this [ __ ] went down man
our whole world [ __ ] turned upside
down because everybody on the gulf coast
of mississippi
thought anybody who looked [ __ ]
gothic at all caused that shooting
yeah i remember that pretty vividly
remember when that [ __ ] happened and
they weren't even gods or anything no
not really they were
they liked km fdm and stuff they were in
more like industrial music
yeah and they didn't even look that no
they just were
whatever they looked cool to me you know
[ __ ] they look dude
i would have hung out with them you know
if i was in high school but the more i
find out about them the more i
definitely
would not have hung out you talked about
how they looked
look at you you're putting words in my
mind you didn't let me finish
based on how they looked i probably
would have hung out with them if i was
in high school at the time
they looked alright i thought they
looked cool and they hung out a lot of
people looked all right
but there's some issues with that school
and there's some issues with some [ __ ]
that those kids [ __ ] did there are a
lot of
a lot of [ __ ] medications and
you see recordings of the dudes they're
kind of [ __ ] all over the place they
can't
you know what i mean they can't stop
[ __ ] talking and [ __ ] they're just
they're nuts you know um probably i'm
gonna say right here eric harris
more than dylan klebold and they're both
absolutely responsible they're both uh
you know horrible mass murderers
but i do kind of feel like you know eric
harris
probably a psychopath um you know and
you know if you read like a lot of his
journals and watch some of their videos
and stuff like that
and there had been complaints about him
from that like for
several years prior um and dylan i feel
like
more uh a depression issue but also
they both had uh obviously rage issues
and i i do kind of feel like i kind of
want to get into it a little bit because
i do kind of feel like bullying was an
issue but i don't think it was as big an
issue
as maybe people uh thought it was
you know what i'm saying uh because i
don't think they were as bullied as much
as
maybe they were putting across they did
kind of feel like
i do kind of feel like they had a little
bit of a paranoia or like a victim
complex
kind of thing you know what i mean going
on yeah uh because they definitely
definitely had some mental health issues
big
time yeah both of them i don't like to
make it you know what they did is
[ __ ]
big deal but i don't like to make a big
deal over the reasons of why the [ __ ]
goes down
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] went down for
[ __ ] [ __ ] reasons really
none of that [ __ ] was important uh it
was more like a natural disaster
because there are a lot of [ __ ] kids
that are just like this that don't do it
you know what i mean yeah there are guys
that are like that lots of them in high
schools that
you know nothing ever happens it's just
to happen to be these particular the
combination of these two dudes
thank you zach in that place at that
time
under the societal conditions of the
time [ __ ] ended up in a mass shooting
and it's pretty sad too because i kind
of feel like the fact that there was a
little bit
of mythologizing about it afterward
because it was such a big media event
i do kind of feel like it maybe um
became a template for uh oh she's gonna
jump up here
became a template for subsequent school
shootings there had been some school
shootings before this this happened in
1999
but um you know the this
at the time was the worst one uh i
believe now virginia tech is the worst
one as far as victim count goes
but this all this was kind of like the
first one of like the media age was all
over the media and i think it kind of
inspired
um some other dudes that had similar
issues to these guys to
kind of act on the [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
yeah it was a lot of things at once it
really was it was just kind of like a
perfect storm
awfulness actually i think i think a lot
of head
we're getting ahead of ourselves really
well we're just doing it a little
overview
it's just the uh yeah the introduction
internet had a lot to do with it the
internet had a lot to do with it
i remember i was there at the time it
was the beginning of the new internet
you know what i mean and uh you had guys
like this
getting access to the internet thinking
that they were basically
kind of like outside of society that
they were in a secret society because
the internet was kind of a secret
society
yeah because definitely eric harris big
time felt like he had he had something
of a god
complex like a lot of psychopaths do he
kind of felt superior to everyone else
like everyone else was stupid compared
to him and
yeah and most of us most of the world at
that time wasn't on the internet and if
you were on the internet
talking to other people who are like you
in other places or getting your hands on
cool music and things that you thought
was real cutting edge and
you know real [ __ ] cool then you felt
better than everybody
yeah and i definitely remember feeling
like that because like me and my friends
felt like that's i mean
i don't know any of this [ __ ] yeah we're
do we're on yeah we're [ __ ] special
god damn it so that was part of it too
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah um and a lot of us felt like that
you know it wasn't just them but i mean
i was [ __ ] blown away during this
time that i could find goth clubs and
events anywhere in the united states
at any time in any city where i wanted
to go through the internet
when other people couldn't yeah because
you know what i mean mundanes couldn't
do that i must be more honest yeah we're
just [ __ ] yeah we're ahead of the
curve
yeah that's what it was i just wanted to
go back because i think trevor asked you
a question about the guy that makes your
the grendizer robots so i guess he's
talking about um but i have to scroll
back
up and i'm afraid to touch anything okay
so maybe you want to scroll it on your
tablet
i mean i have to touch things sometimes
because i have to scroll through my
notes
trevor it's kind of up it's it's kind of
up a little way
you know what i mean way up at the top
well not
all the way at the top but it's up there
a little bit hey tom random question
does that guy who makes a grand eyes or
makes the granddaughter in other things
does he make gundams no ah no
no gundam he just does mostly go nagai
1970s uh super robot stuff from a
japanese dude named go go nagai it's
kind of like their version i guess like
stan lee
you know but uh no no gundam that was
80s
yeah thank you very much sidequest hero
still can't do patreon again yet but i
love the show thanks for the hours of
entertainment well you're very welcome
thank you very much for hanging out with
us and for supporting the show
we have a good time doing this sorry we
didn't do as many this past week but you
know
uh germs that was bad you guys
all right so we do actually have a few
shout outs to do
before we kind of get into the case and
like i said this is kind of a
complicated
case so we probably need a while to get
through all of it
um i think i said this on a few of the
matinee shows or something like that but
uh ken who i don't know if he's here yet
or not uh sent me two jars of
really nice organic cashew butter so i'm
very very excited yeah i've been eating
that like on toast and it's like
delicious so thank you very much for
that
lily sent us a damn blu-ray yeah well i
was gonna get i was going through my
legs
let's see i have a list right here she's
got a lip see she's [ __ ] organized
well yeah i can't i can't just like go
around doing [ __ ] half-assed
it would never get done otherwise
everything
i wanted to say we have a new patron
named noah
so thank you very much and welcome also
louis just sent us a movie yesterday
which actually i had never heard of
when did it come out 2016 or 2018 i
can't remember
but it's like fairly recent and the
movie's called
wind river yeah we already watched it
and we actually figured with like last
night we were kind of like
it was kind of early so i was like well
we don't have to watch you know we don't
have to start spartacus yet let's watch
this it's like
that sounds pretty good it's a thriller
and stuff and it's based on a true story
so we actually watched it it was like
really really good so we'll probably
talk about that on sunday's
matinee show uh you know it's it's it's
unusual that we actually like
the day that we get a movie we actually
like have time to watch the movie
yeah so i was like kind of excited we
got a lot of movies backed up that's
what i mean i have this big
well and like i said that's why i today
i started recording
like new movie reviews like just me like
talking about horror movies i'm gonna do
old ones new ones [ __ ] like that's like
ones you don't really care about or once
you don't want to watch
because it's just like i have you know
we have a pile of them in there
um i have a huge list of old ones and
new ones that i want to see or that
people have recommended they're like hey
do you want on this hey doing that so i
keep like a big list about it
um so and i just felt like man we're
getting so behind
so i need to just start doing something
on my own so i'm gonna start doing
a couple of weeks so i actually recorded
the first couple today they're gonna
start going up like april 1st i think
but uh yeah so i'm kind of excited about
it i think that'll be super fun
i have just have so many so many movies
that i
really need to get to that i really want
to see that i just haven't had time to
watch so at least that'll give me an
excuse
like i said just like my horror book
review show gave an excuse to like read
a bunch of new horror books
which i'm really uh i'm really big in
that actually it's nice to catch up on
some [ __ ]
in fact tj showed up hey you guys
sup t did you see thank you dermot thank
you very much
glad i'm not the one the only one who
keeps lists for everything
i get every literally every single
morning i get up and make a list that
says
monday and then i list every single
thing that i have to do on that day and
then i
mark it off we had a list we had a list
of everybody who sent us
blu-rays and she lost and i lost it so i
try to keep things organized but it
doesn't always work out
well sometimes like because i i like to
write everything down like some things i
have typed
um i'm kind of disorganized but
organized at the same time like
if somebody came in here and needed to
find something they probably would not
be able to find it but i usually know
where it is not always sometimes if it
was a long time ago i was like
oh i know i made a list for that where
the [ __ ] did i put it and then i can't
find it
but i haven't i have a notebook where i
i like to write everything down and then
i try to keep and then sometimes what
happens is like i'll make a list like on
a piece of paper like i'll write it down
and then later like you know months
later
um i'll think i'll just see the back of
it or something and be like oh that i
don't need that
piece of paper anymore let's just scrap
and then i'll throw it away and then
i'll be like oh [ __ ] that had like some
important [ __ ] on it and then it got
thrown out so you know
yeah hey t i saw i saw red sun again
after mentioning it
i rented it it was like three bucks
three or four dollars i think on
um on amazon and it was even better than
i remembered it
so on second viewing it was [ __ ] it
was really good there was a lot of stuff
i forgot about it
like i forgot batman was in it yeah i
forgot russian back and forth
and russian batman and russian wonder
woman was in there now she's not russian
she's not russian yeah she's from where
she's supposed to be oh i forgot about
that
yeah it wasn't even that long ago that
we saw that and i already forgot
yeah there's a russian version of batman
and i'm like damn that's it
that's me
if thomas is rushing back yeah i'm
[ __ ] rushing batman
oh you should dress like that yeah
that'd be a halloween costume oh yeah
that
would be a good halloween costume it's
easy to do it's just gray bdus
with the damn bat with a [ __ ] mask
and a cape
with a damn russian [ __ ] snow cap on
there yeah there you go that'd be right
gloves and it's [ __ ]
like he'd have like knee-high uh new
rocks would work
yeah there you go yeah you've already
been batman
he was a [ __ ] he was a counter uh he
was a terrorist basically
but he was trying to overthrow a [ __ ]
superman because he was a [ __ ]
dictator so he was
he was a good guy but he was [ __ ]
real ruthless yeah
yeah good guy he was kind of like the
punisher
yeah yeah good good for certain
definitions of good
yeah good is
it's a slightly sliding scale
but yeah so i think that was uh all the
shout outs that i had
so yeah so i'm gonna show you right now
do you see where this little
this little gray square is up here you
see that and that's the top of the page
yeah okay so look at all of that yeah
okay so we well that's not that's not
well that means i'm gonna have to
[ __ ] do all kinds of kitty action too
let cats out
let cats in is she ins she is inside
right she's in right now i think she
just tried to get in dark see
she wants to go out she just came up um
just
she just came up here to the corner and
she was like looking longingly at the
corner of the dead man i could jump up
on that and knock all your [ __ ] off last
night we found her
by the pond like just she was standing
by the side of the pond
and there were how many birds were in
there like how many sand hill cranes
yeah there were two one two of them are
three of them two
two of them and they were yeah and they
were standing in the water and they were
sleeping
like standing up and she was just like
sitting there looking at them going what
are those weird birds doing
yeah but shouting the light on her i see
her eyes and her collar down into the
pond
and go you better come here you better
come here she wouldn't come so i went
over there to see what it was
and she's standing by these birds
looking at them going like she's like
look daddy what are they doing
why why they're sleeping come on
why because they're big you know
sandhill cranes what four feet tall
yeah three and a half to four details
yeah yeah they're big they're big ass
birds
if you've never seen one before they are
juggling yeah
they're not dangerous or anything but
then that's where the myth of the
mothman
may have come from i suspect uh that
much so it could have been a big ass owl
too
but i do kind of feel like maybe sand
hill crane because
that is maybe a bird that's not as
common in that part of the world so they
wouldn't have
been as used to seeing it because those
birds are [ __ ] huge like when they're
flying
and they're very intelligent they'll
come right up right up to you and
tap on your window or tap on your door
try to get you to open the door because
they want food excuse me excuse me and
if you open the door up
and stay there long enough they'll walk
into the house yeah
they turn their little red eye toward
you and they'd be like yeah
that's you have to have children with
them yeah i want you to feed the
children they'll sit there and let you
feed the child because they always go in
little family groups
they're either in pears or a pear and
they're kids yeah they'll eat right out
of your hand
well the ones around here will you're
you're technical technically you're not
supposed to
do and really i still they're really
loud i stopped doing it because they
started to demand
[Laughter]
who's knocking my [ __ ] door you open
up this birds
get out of here and they won't leave
that's going so [ __ ] fun get out get
out of here and they're like
no no i'm coming in i got to feed these
children
you have food in here come on give it up
i know [ __ ] man one time i was sitting
here by
office working and like i heard like
bang bang bang bang bang and i was like
what the [ __ ] and then like i looked out
there
there's like a window right there in the
hall like by the bathroom where the cat
tree is
and there was like that's a [ __ ]
santa crane just standing there like
looking at it
she said she didn't like she didn't see
gargoyle so remember
yeah i remember that i i kind of want to
watch that again yeah you know what i
mean
it was good for made for tv he had good
costumes for the day
there were some decent made-for-tv
movies i feel like back in the 70s and
80s
yeah you know it was some [ __ ] matter of
fact i was just
i was just talking about uh one made for
tv movie
one of my movie reviews because i was
reviewing uh
threads from 1984 which is british made
for tv but then we had one
we had the equivalent called the day
after so i was like talking about that
earlier but that won't be out until next
month so don't get too excited
all right so are we ready to talk about
uh
columbine yeah
yeah go ahead you are going to help me
right you're not just going to there we
go
okay good good good because i was just
like i mean i don't know all the little
details you got everything written down
but i i remember you know i remember a
lot of it you know i was there during it
not there but
during those times you know everybody
was paying attention to what the hell
was going on and
i just remember the the tone of the time
and
you know everything that came out i
remember what howard stern was saying
about it you know i remember
i remember yeah i mean i remember too i
graduated from high school
nine years before this but high school
hadn't changed all that much
like in this nine years subsequently so
it so i could still kind of like
picture what the [ __ ] was going on with
[ __ ] but yeah internet had a lot to do
with this
and so and and and i think society's
reaction to marilyn manson also [ __ ]
factored into a lot of it which is weird
because it's like they weren't even that
into maryland they weren't into maryland
not really some reason he got kind of
but it's just kind of it
well i feel like this almost kind of
like spurred off
a second wave of satanic panic kind of
[ __ ] yeah because when this happened
um it was kind of like now sadly it's
just kind of like oh another school
shooting there's another one
but back in the day that that was kind
of like a big deal because it didn't
really happen that often there had been
one in um
dunblane scotland before because i
actually was uh there when that happened
i think it was 95 or 96
but um we're a dude just a crazy dude
just like walked in and killed a bunch
of preschoolers
but when this [ __ ] started to happen i
think like in the 70s
when shoot the fbi uh
recommended that the federal government
order
local news and national national news
to not announce school shootings that it
would fuel to make more of them they
were right a lot of psychologists
you know that they should have not
talked about that [ __ ] at a national
level
because the dudes that do it are trying
to get national attention
yeah yeah a global attention so you have
to deny them that
and they do it for a lot of other crimes
that you never hear about like bomics
which is actually what the columbine
massacre was supposed to be
there's a lot of bombings and i have a
background
in that business you know i mean uh
through in terms of
helping to train law enforcement through
post blast investigation techniques and
stuff
but can there's a lot of bombings you
will never hear about them
never a lot of them are letter bombs a
lot of them are little bitty
male me bombs left in people's front
doors
[ __ ] like that they just don't talk
about them because you'll just create
more of them
and really school shootings should have
been the same way but they just can't
resist
they can't resist the [ __ ] i was i was
reading i don't know if other countries
do this as well but i was reading i
think it was
thank you zack have you ever noticed how
the mass shooter has kind of replaced
the serial killer in terms of prevalence
and coverage yeah it's definitely
um serial killing has kind of declined
um you know for reasons we've talked
about before i think i don't you know
environmental reasons environmental
reasons it's just you know it's it's not
as easy to get away with anymore blah
blah blah so i do think that matthew
should be an exceptional repression
yeah but i do think that mass shootings
have gone up um
you know the crime is still not as bad
as i think people are perceiving but
what i was going to say was that
i don't know if other countries have
done this as well but i read somewhere
please if anyone knows
for sure tell me i think that new
zealand has adopted a policy
that when they are first reporting if
there's a shooting or something like
there's some kind of terroristic
somebody that does something for
attention
um they can report the perpetrator's
name the first time they report it after
that they are not allowed
to say the person's name for that exact
reason because they do not want
them getting any kind of glorification
or anything like that so they just call
them the shooter or whatever
you know so a lot of people are
advocating why don't we just call them
like
that [ __ ] or something like or that
douchebag or something like that um
just so they don't get the attention
that they deserve because the sad thing
about it is that
you know particularly with the columbine
shooting with a lot of like sandy hook
all that kind of stuff
a lot of people can name you know the
perpetrators harder to name the victims
which is really really sad
school shootings school bombings in the
united states go all the way back to the
[ __ ] 1600s before the united states
they were doing it all the way back then
it's just that it was a
much smaller schools and word of it
hardly ever left the town it never
really became a thing
you know yeah i mean yeah so so it does
seem like
well and we've talked about this before
too i think
you know in a lot of ways mass media
immediate mass media is good but it also
gives you an inflated sense of how much
crime is out there because
before there'd be [ __ ] bad [ __ ] going
all the time but you just wouldn't hear
about it because
it wasn't reported like in your local
[ __ ] but now everybody hears about
everything all the time
so it just seems like everything yeah
like the world is falling apart
it's really not like any more than it is
and nothing is in the united states
right now gun violence is [ __ ] low
it's much lower now than it was in the
1970s 1970s was a lot worse
and here's another thing well 70s and
80s were really really bad
and here's another thing the united
states even though it has a i think it
has like
two guns for every person in it all
right it still has a
if you actually look at the true
statistics not the inflated ones where
they're
putting in police shootings then they're
putting in suicides
that that doesn't count we're talking
about [ __ ] real [ __ ] crimes you
know what i mean
somebody killing an innocent person the
[ __ ] where two
dudes are fighting and shooting at each
other over drugs i don't really
if you take that out of it you're st
even if you left a lot of that in there
i think brazil's homicide rate is still
higher
per capita well i'm pretty sure much
higher i'm sure brazil is
i think brazil is higher i think it
fluctuates between us and brazil and
maybe there's one in central america
somewhere that's higher but
and in brazil [ __ ] civilian gun
ownership is totally banned
but they're everywhere every [ __ ]
where and you know where they get them
from the cops
cops sell them why do the cops sell them
because the cops are crooked
okay you don't pay your cops and [ __ ]
the cops
well a lot it's not so much the cops are
crooked
the cops will sell guns to ex-military
friends of theirs
because they are because the brazilian
police
are restricted and can't really
fight or they can't really fight the
drug cartels the drug cartels have all
the [ __ ] guns that they want they're
[ __ ] ak-47 machine guns and [ __ ]
it it brazil is a gigantic cluster [ __ ]
a gigantic cluster [ __ ] and nobody's
honest uh
where are the guns coming from rich
politicians they just take money and
[ __ ] smuggle them in
and sell them [ __ ] secretly through
[ __ ] police stations and through drug
cart just because just because a person
is in the ruling class or an elected
official that doesn't mean they're
honest
that doesn't mean that they love you all
right
okay doesn't mean that they give a [ __ ]
about you they're still selling drugs
and guns
to their own people because there's
money
you know and so you just systems
and when you have a low trust society no
system you install will work because you
just can't trust anybody
you know and that's eventually what
happens to big countries
eventually if they're just part of the
way
societies evolve under these conditions
right now
but uh yeah
that's all i'm going to say about it i'm
going to say that all right so
let's go back to 1999 as i said at the
time
the columbine massacre the largest
school shooting at the time i think
there had been one prior to that
um didn't like charles whitman like the
texas sniper
that i don't know if they considered
that technically a school shooting even
though it happened like on a college
campus i don't know there's
i don't i don't know but that that was
actually more
i actually wanted to do a show about him
whitman was the uh
the tower shooter right yeah yeah yeah
he would yeah i guess you could kind of
call that a school it was a novice he
was random he was just
on top of a tower shooting at anything
he could see yeah because i think he
shot some other people yeah he was like
happened to be a camper yeah
i think that's why they don't consider
that a school shooting because he
actually did
kill more people um you know not that
that makes it any i put that in
f as natural disaster though he had a
damn [ __ ] brain tumor in his head the
side of the golf ball
yeah like hearing voices and [ __ ] i have
put that in the poll a couple times but
it never gets enough votes to win but
eventually i would like to
do a show about that guy because he was
kind of interesting that was an
interesting uh case
yeah but so yeah so this one as i said
happened in april of 1999
two senior students uh eric harris and
dylan klebold
ended up murdering 12 students and one
teacher and then
killed themselves but [ __ ] that um
so yeah so let's get into
their background a little bit because
like i said i think this is kind of
important because
the thing about the columbine massacre
it's been so
you know kind of picked over for their
motives and everything because i think
it scared people
these two kids seemed so quote unquote
normal
and that they would do something like
this
but i don't know there's just so much
and i think that there's no one cause
for why they
they of all people like snapped and did
the [ __ ] i will say from the outset
and um i watched a couple other like
psychiatrists and things like that
talking about this
that from their standpoint they thought
that
eric harris um
likely would have done this without
dylan klebold
but they don't think that the opposite
is true they don't think dylan would
have done this on his own
you know what i'm saying um but eric
harris definitely would have
because from his writings and stuff like
that he definitely seems like he had
a psychotic um you know
or he was he was basically a psychopath
you know
um so yeah so we'll get into that
um but otherwise it's weird because on
the surface they seemed like very normal
which like i said i think scared a lot
of people and i think that's kind of
what maybe spurred
people later into looking for reasons
it's like oh they were wearing a black
trench coats and they liked km fdm so
they must have been goths and they were
in the trench coat mafia which they
weren't
um you know and they were satan
worshipers and they were this and that
and the other they were nazis or
something
and it's like a lot of that [ __ ] was
just not true
so but you know every time this happens
they always have to look for some reason
and if they can blame
some group of outsiders that nobody
particularly likes or nobody understands
then all the better
so and i feel like that really did
happen big time in this case
so eric harris born in 1981
he was actually raised in colorado mom
was a homemaker his dad
was uh in the air force he was a
transport pilot
they moved around you know a lot because
it was a military family or whatever
um his parents didn't think anything was
wrong with him they thought he was just
like a typical kid
um you know he had a hard time like
moving around [ __ ] because he had to
leave his friends
but um you know nothing
out of the ordinary you know what i mean
just for any kind of military brat that
had to
move around a lot um he said too that
when he was younger he started saying
like in his journals and things that
people made fun of the way he looked
even though to me
like his appearance not some not the way
he dressed because
from the pictures from the time that
he's talking about
he looked like just a normal kid you
know what i mean he didn't look
all goffed out or anything like that he
just looked like a regular
preppy kid you know yeah um
so he met dylan klebold when they were
both in
seventh grade um
but he goes so so they'd known each
other for quite a long time and were
kind of like best friends they were
pretty much
inseparable which ended up being not
such a great thing because i think they
both
fed into each other's
mental health issues in a horrific kind
of way
so eric harris um enters columbine high
school in 1995 as a freshman
um and as i said this this kind of
ties into the fact that i think there
was a lot of
[ __ ] afterwards about oh all these kids
at the school picked on him and he
didn't have any friends and he was a
loner and he was just taking revenge
but from a lot of the stuff that i found
out like a couple people said yeah a
couple people picked on him but it
wasn't
that big a thing he did have a lot of
friends
um he played sports on the soccer team
um you know he dated girls sometimes
you know not anything long-term or
serious or anything like that but it
didn't
he did say you know people made fun of
how he looked and he did get picked on a
little bit
but i don't feel like it was anything
that would
merit like what ended up happening you
know what i mean i kind of feel like he
had a little bit
you know and this is armchair
psychologizing i guess but i do kind of
feel like he had a little bit of a
persecution complex maybe
um and also a little bit of a
superiority complex
like you said which kind of happened a
lot with kids that were
you know smarter or were kind of into
cool [ __ ] and
kind of felt like oh everyone else was
beneath you because they were
well the rest of the world wasn't online
yeah that tail so it's kind of like you
were
coming in underneath their radar yeah
that you were had access to [ __ ] that
other people didn't have
you had access to information other
people didn't have you could order [ __ ]
that other people couldn't get
in your in your location because you
were doing online purchases
way ahead of anybody else so you did
feel like you had a leg up over on
people you know
yeah you're like these idiots they don't
even know what they don't even
they can't even [ __ ] order anything
online
you know [ __ ] we were [ __ ] what 30
years ahead 25 years ahead
i guess so yeah yeah so it's just weird
yeah ryan 25 years ahead i guess it was
probably more like
when you really looked at it it was
probably more like about eight years
ahead
yeah yeah because i think that became
more common within about eight years
yeah it totally yeah of that time um
yeah ryan's pointing out too that the
whole thing about
asking somebody do you believe in god
and then shooting them that
uh is also a little bit of a myth which
uh
evangelical christians kind of ran with
uh which i'll get into a little bit
when i kind of talk about the timeline
of the shooting but yeah so that was
another big misconception about it that
like i said that that has just become
part of the [ __ ] legend i guess if
you want to use that word
like surrounding the crime but yeah so
so there were but you know there were
some early like danger signs so he's in
high school like he asked this girl um
named tiffany who was in his german
class and uh
he went to homecoming with her and then
you know but it wasn't anything serious
or anything i guess maybe he asked her
out again and she said no
and what he did was he
faked a suicide for her benefit
which a little bit of a red flag there
gotta say
um you know what i mean and uh so then
like when she saw him and freaked out he
laughed at her
you know i mean so a little bit of a
psycho um so
dylan a little bit different he was also
born in colorado
but i don't think that uh he moved
around
as much if you see like his poor mom
i kind of feel bad for her sue cleveland
she's done like a bunch of ted talks she
wrote a book and stuff about
you know what what happened in the
aftermath of uh
you know of the school shooting and like
her coming having to come to terms with
her son being one of the shooters which
you know was horrible and how could she
not know that all this was going on and
blah blah blah
and um you know if you kind of watch her
ted talk and like read some of the stuff
she says she's like a really
man i i really would not have want to be
put in that like [ __ ] situation
but she says this is kind of interesting
i don't know how much
stock i place in this but she says that
when
uh dylan was born she had this really
really weird feeling
that he was going to quote unquote bring
her great sorrow
and i was like guess you were right
about that it's almost like she had like
a premonition
um so her
uh so dylan was kind of was real sickly
like when he was a baby like
he came out um you know he had some kind
of condition
and uh so he was real sick but he got
over it
um so basically they uh
dylan was raised a lutheran both his
parents were
pacifists and they were really into the
church and everything um
you know him and his brother were both
you know went to church and they
believed all that kind of stuff
and uh so basically they also had kind
of some jewish stuff because i guess one
side of the family like the grandfather
or something like that was jewish
so he seemed like real
uh gifted when he was a kid but
he he was real um real shy
real introverted um a lot of people
commented on that uh you know that he
just kind of
you know he just seemed like not to make
friends easily because he was just like
really quiet
and a lot of people did comment on it so
we found it difficult to make friends
however uh just like eric harris even
though it became kind of the
perception later that they were
targeting jocks or people that played
sports both of them played sports which
i thought was like really weird
like i said eric harris was a soccer
player um dylan also played
soccer he also played baseball um you
know so it wasn't like
they were just these little skinny nerdy
like not
physically active like weirdos that had
no friends it's like they seemed like
pretty normal you know what i mean um
well it was because the schools they
went to
well i don't know i don't know how much
that i went to you had to you had to do
um
uh what was gold what was that [ __ ] what
did they call that [ __ ] it was
it was a course you had to well yeah
but you but we didn't have to play
baseball or anything you just had to go
do pe you had to do like your exercises
at the beginning sometimes
you'd you know you'd play basketball or
they'd do [ __ ] you know other people
yeah but they're but when they usually
say that people did sports in high
school that doesn't just mean pe
that means you did like you went on the
team
and you played teams yeah we didn't have
to do that you had to take on a varsity
you had to take pe
obviously um but you didn't have to be
on
a sports team you know what i mean
that's that's like after school [ __ ]
that's like
you know extracurricular activities so
they were they were doing
extracurriculars happening though
activities yeah what in pe no all the
extracurricular stuff
yeah after school well i just wanted to
depend on what school you were in the
school i was in brazil
no you wanted to stay in lake that's one
way all the waves would be as [ __ ]
smoke weed well yeah work on the damn
yearbook
go to fencing class yeah i went to
fencing class then you make out with
some check
just whatever you were taking just
whatever you know what i mean
because you know you you might not be
able to get to her because she probably
lived far from you
you know so yeah
yeah yeah you had you had to make your
move at school
yeah i was um i was just you didn't have
that kind of experience in high school
high school a positive experience for
you yeah okay junior high
junior high wasn't i hated junior high
but high school was much much better i
loved it
because in high school i mean i love
telemetry well because like i'm a nerd
so i got really into school
um and i really liked elementary school
and all my teachers loved me
junior high i kind of hated um because
it was kind of an awkward
time and i got picked on a lot um but
high school was like way better because
i kind of got
into like a peer group of like other
like punk rockers and
you know band geeks and stuff like that
so we had like a big group that hung out
maniac said the same thing he's in
trauma to to get the chicks yeah that's
why i went to it too
singing doing the dab what was it stereo
i had fun at it you know what were you
saying jay
um i don't remember what i was saying um
i'm talking about what no it's i wasn't
i wasn't drunk i didn't do this i'm
getting shocked just talking about oh
yeah because
it's just sometimes i'm i'm i have a
thing that i'm doing with my
that i'm talking then you kind of like
interrupt that and i forget where i was
going
i wasn't in i was in a bunch of clubs in
high school
i was in uh i was in chorus
i was in let me see i was an art club i
was in key club
i wasn't some other [ __ ] too i don't
even remember but um
you know drama had all the cute girls in
it well not true
they had cute girls they didn't have all
didn't have like you know
yeah it did it it had it had like a cute
kind of like goth punk rock type
girls were in it was they were in drama
yeah a lot of them yeah that's just you
know
yeah we're having fun yeah yeah
well yeah that's like i said i actually
kind of liked high school i liked all
school accept college i hated college
oh i liked college [ __ ] the only the
only school i didn't like was junior
high
i just i really didn't like junior high
completed one semester and then [ __ ]
went back for a couple months and i said
[ __ ] this man i was tired of being bored
and i don't like these [ __ ] i'm
getting out of here
so that's it michael shafer did you
belong to the physics club
is that a breakfast club reference no i
wasn't in the chess club either but you
know what i mean
i was but i was in like all the already
[ __ ] in the in the choir and stuff
um all right so both kids both of the uh
eric harris and dylan klebold
worked together at blackjack pizza uh
and also they were both on the
i guess they had a bowling class at the
school so they were both into bowling as
well
and uh you know both kind of computer
geeks
now interestingly a lot of the when they
kind of interviewed a lot of this
of their schoolmates at least the ones
that survived sadly
um they said yeah eric was real
kind of outgoing real charismatic kind
of likable
nice but um the thing about it and this
is kind of what leads me to
suspect that eric harris was probably
psycho
it was probably a psychopath was that he
took great pride in his ability to
deceive others he basically said in his
journals um that he just lied all the
time and that he was
proud of the fact that he was really
good at making people
believe whatever they wanted about him
that he was like this super nice guy
but really like the [ __ ] that he wrote
was straight up horrifying
you know what i mean yep but at the time
also some people did note that he also
had some anger issues
um he would get real uh he would kind of
like explode into anger at like very
small slights
you know things like that um and would
amp [ __ ] up like really really quick
like hey i'm gonna blow you up i'm gonna
build a bomb and
blow you up you know what i mean and
this is like a few years before
the attack you know what i'm saying so
you know there were red flags
far in advance of what happened it's
just that
you know it's really easy to kind of
monday morning quarterback and yeah
oh people should have should have seen
and [ __ ] you know but people
the thing about it is people did
intervene they did get
arrested a couple times they did get you
know they had to go to anger management
they did actually get in trouble a few
times for the [ __ ] that they
pulled like a year or two prior to this
happening
but i kind of feel like because
something like this hadn't happened
to this extent to this kind of
widespread mass media
you know uh you know everyone knowing
about it
i do kind of feel like people didn't
really think that much about it they're
just like oh there's just these kids and
they're just being
[ __ ] you know like teenage boys are
being [ __ ] yeah what you're
describing was was common
that and that's what i mean a lot of
kids up like that
and then they don't go on to do this so
it's really hard
you know it's easy to say in hindsight
like after they've killed all these
people
it's like yeah you should have seen this
that and the other thing but it's like
a lot of kids act the way they acted the
same guys who'd be like i'm gonna blow
you up oh yeah
i'm gonna get my machine gun yeah that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they didn't do anything yeah yeah and
then a couple years later he's like cool
you're hanging out with him yeah that's
what i mean
most people grow out of it yeah well
[ __ ] hormones
99 of dudes that say stupid [ __ ] like
that
will never act on it but you never know
which one's going to
you know what i mean that's what's scary
dj maniac is saying it's not like in my
day where we had a guy that called in
bomb threats on the regular just to get
us out of class yeah we had that happen
too
and it's like it wasn't like nowadays
they'd probably call in the [ __ ] fbi
in your ass if he did that [ __ ]
back then back then it would be like a
joke yeah it'd be it would be like oh
there's
there's those kids there's ross calling
in another [ __ ] bomb threat again
they're pulling the fire alarm they used
to do that a lot i had
well [ __ ] it wasn't just me i mean
pretty much everybody
back in our day we had the feeling we
were just kind of immune that yeah
nothing would happen to us yeah i feel
like mostly right
i feel like most kids feel like that i
know you know what's weird i never felt
like that even when i was a kid i was
always like really really
really aware of the fact that i could
die here man set this on fire here see
that look how that's burning
yeah that's burning go through that
dumpster you know then the other guy
okay and then the [ __ ] dumpster a
dumpster fire
yeah yeah they were real well i know
you know why why is that a thing that's
because yeah
yeah i think it was a big deal you know
well i mean when i was a kid and [ __ ]
i'm a girl
when i was a kid i got a chemistry set
and i was super excited like
when i don't remember how old i was and
i understand maybe and the first thing i
try to do is make explosives
yeah i mean you know like i said i'm a
girl i wasn't gonna hurt anybody i was
just curious well we grew up very
different than the
modern kids you know what i mean
nowadays i think to keep them locked up
[ __ ] we were just as long as we were
back we were little kids running around
like wild animals
[ __ ] long as we were back before the
[ __ ] street lights were you know when
the street lights came on we were good
yeah yeah going down into the [ __ ]
sewage systems and [ __ ] looking for the
giant ants
just anything yeah so you know well my
brother and his friends used to go out
in the woods and
blow [ __ ] up with fire that thing's on
fire you know out in the [ __ ] woods
and
[ __ ] you know blow up their gi joe
figures and strap them to bottle rockets
we made a [ __ ] swing yeah you know
out of a rope
and uh would make a huge [ __ ] bonfire
and swing through the
bonfire that was a good one yeah yeah
yeah nowadays they'd probably call the
[ __ ] law on you and then they'd lock
you up and see what was wrong with you
or something
do brain surgery on you well there was
i'm gonna say right now there was
definitely something wrong with these
two
yeah well there was on it but this is
you know what i mean yeah but for us it
was just called growing up
yeah having fun but like i said the
scary thing is that
you know a lot of this kind of behavior
is not all that uncommon
no particularly among teenage boys yeah
and um
you don't know which one of them you
know which one of them are actually
going to [ __ ]
go on to do crazy [ __ ]
this was synergy between these two kids
and [ __ ] their friends and the entire
school
and the whole [ __ ] town and the
teachers the teachers were also involved
in this
although as i said these two i mean they
both had journals they had [ __ ] like
that
even in their very very early you know
from the very early time that they were
at
columbine they basically they didn't
even
care about who it was or taking revenge
or anything like that they basically
just wanted to kill everybody
because they wanted to they wanted to
destroy the school
yeah but they i mean they had fantasies
about just killing
everyone they came across um so i kind
of feel like it was more
i don't even think it was as simple as
oh we're gonna take revenge on people
that bully does because they just wanted
to kill everybody they didn't give a
[ __ ]
from whatever from what i remember their
friends
saying in interviews is that they wanted
to just destroy the school because they
hated it
they didn't like the town either but
they liked all their friends they just
wanted everybody to remember
and they wanted to be responsible for
destroying the school
yeah it was something that it just gave
them a chub yeah they like school
like they just thought it was like super
cool to just let's just kill a bunch of
people and we'll be
and we'll be infamous yeah everybody
will know us yeah i wonder
um and i'm sure i'm not the only person
that has noticed this
i wonder had they seen the movie
heathers
from 1990 that came out nine years prior
because in that movie
jd wearing a black trench coat uh
builds a bomb and is gonna blow up the
school and he puts it under the
so i wonder if some if if he kind of got
the idea and he
and and he kind of espouses this kind of
philosophy where it's
where he's kind of like trying to
justify it you know what i mean yeah
but it might be coincidence it might be
but it's possible that they saw it
because it came out
like nine years before they were a
little young yeah
they would have considered that like an
old person's movie i think by that time
that wasn't [ __ ] cool i don't think
christian slater
well i don't know maybe yeah girls
girls their age would have liked it i
don't think guys their age would have
liked that
yeah it's like i said it's hard to say
but it's just like really interesting
that a lot of the [ __ ] they say
sounds very much like [ __ ] that jd said
in heather's and the fact that he
wore the same thing that they wore maybe
they did and did the same kind of [ __ ]
that they you know
i'm just speculating well winona was in
it
so you know they probably watched
beetlejuice know they were probably into
you know
alien excuse in what alien three
maybe maybe they saw that maybe they
were one of the rider fans
yeah see it could be she was cute goth
girl maybe they were looking at that
yeah her name was soren heathers yeah
maybe
so uh so also at the high school they
um also were they did some kind of [ __ ]
like you they did like school play type
of sh
type [ __ ] um they were kind of av
kind of people they did you know video
productions and stuff they made little
movies
[ __ ] like that and they were also as i
said they were real interested in
computers and like i said this was 1999
still
kind of early in the whole internet sort
of thing so
they actually helped to maintain the
school's computer
server interestingly um so
as i said they weren't i'm not saying
that they weren't
bullied but i kind of feel like there
was a narrative of them being these
friendless loser outcasts and that
is really not the case they actually
were kind of involved
in a lot of stuff in the school they had
like a pretty wide
circle of friends so they weren't just
these loveless
i think to a large extent they kind of
perceived themselves that way though
um you know understanding was it was a
kind of like a school made up of
factions
well every high school was like that
though it was a very mainstream
kind of upper middle class or nouveau
rich kind of
[ __ ] um neighborhood of i guess you
could say yuppie parents
um it was an all-new area
and they built this school and it was
kind of like the best school in the area
the kids there were mostly very
mainstream and kind of
yuppie-ish and they wore these red base
or white baseball caps called [ __ ]
they called themselves little white hats
and they were sports fans
and uh you know they like jocks and [ __ ]
um the
the teachers for the most part were the
same kind of people as their parents
they were kind of yuppie-ish in a way
and they kind of favored these
mainstream kids
the kids that didn't fit into that group
was the kids that
harrison clay bowled his destiny how do
you say it again
it's cleveland klebold yeah um they fit
in with
with a smaller group kids that were
kind of outcasts in a way but they i
would have called them the cool kids
in a way um you know they liked kind of
alternative type fashions and stuff and
other kind of music they weren't real
mainstream
anyway when any of these kids got in
trouble the teachers would crack down
harder on them than they would on any of
these little white hats
now some of the white hats were real
kiss asses to the jocks
and they were kind of they were the ones
that really didn't have what it would
take to [ __ ]
be a jock maybe because they were a
little overweight or whatever
so they kind of make sport of these kids
and try to [ __ ] with them to get the
jocks and pressed
which that was the same kind of thing i
noticed in some of the schools that i
went to especially
trenton high i got along well with
[ __ ] jocks
with my boy he's probably in the
comments section
but then uh eric eric was one of them he
was a really good [ __ ] hockey player
and he was
we loved him he and he was cool as [ __ ]
none of the jocks ever bothered us it
was always the guys who wanted to be
jocks that couldn't make it
you know i'm talking about it was like
the fourth echelon
it was those guys the ones you had to
watch because they were they were betas
and they were trying to become alphas
well there was a synergy between all
these groups that slowly built up and i
think most of it built up
in these two kids head they were
intensifying it
they'd go out and they'd [ __ ] with them
and they get [ __ ] back with you know
it was like yeah because they bullied
people
yeah they were doing it too it was back
and forth and back and forth and they
worked themselves up into a frenzy where
eventually they were gonna say we're
gonna [ __ ] destroy the school
that's what it was and and based on
everything i
remember of the case and i'm i'm pretty
confident my memory is correct and maybe
my information isn't as up to date as
yours jenny because you've been
you did your um you did the more recent
research than me of course
um i think a lot of it ultimately was
getting back at the entire damn town
and the thing about it is that that's
scary to me is that it doesn't really
matter that it was that town it doesn't
matter it could have happened to anybody
because like i said you know i grew up
yeah you know goth in the school too
it's like thank you zack um
he says if it says anything when i was
in third grade during the bush
administration
they would put posts post-its over
nudity and old paintings and art books i
remember that actually
i i saw a couple like books in the
library that had that like some like
[ __ ]
rembrandts in chile or rubens or
something like that where there was a
lot of nudity in there they kind of pay
[ __ ] over it that's ridiculous
but yeah so i remember i mean i remember
feeling like that when i was in school
more junior high than high school but
high school as well you know oh this
town is so lame it's like you know we
don't have this we don't have that
everyone's so stupid it's like i kind of
feel like that's a pretty common
thing for teenagers to feel especially
if you're like
a little bit different or you kind of
perceive yourself to be a little bit
different
so i do kind of feel like it's not
unusual what these dudes felt it's just
unusual the [ __ ] extent the to which
they took it
and i think that that was exacerbated
big time
by their mental problems because i
definitely like i said eric harris i
definitely do think was a psychopath for
sure i would like to see a blood test on
these boys
i'd like to know what their free
testosterone levels were and what what
part would do a whole oh no ecology now
that he's all that he thinks
that he thinks that the cause is the
root and cause of everything now
i'll [ __ ] with you it's like when you
have a hammer every problem looks like a
nail it's that kind of situation
that's not what i i would like to see
the [ __ ] blood count their their
their entire blood analysis
i'd like to see their [ __ ] free
testosterone and also like
see what kind of farm what kind of
pharmaceuticals they were on
if they were on some of them crazy pills
and they had real high testosterone
counts
yeah it'd make make you real [ __ ]
crazy the stream crashed
just telling you yeah that's cause i was
talking about farmer college don't know
i think they can still hear us
yeah i don't know can you guys feel
yours
well i don't know it's like it's really
hard for me to keep on with it because i
can't really see what's going on
because my [ __ ] stopped oh
god damn it one hour yeah they can still
see and hear us
that's weird it's weirded it's that's
weird man because
it's totally frozen on this side guys i
don't know
maybe i'll just yeah it's makes us want
to just restart restart this [ __ ]
well i don't know should i just keep
talking until it won't let me anymore
i don't really know you still have
anything look
okay that's [ __ ] crazy what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this [ __ ]
man you tell me i don't know it's your
laptop i'm going to [ __ ] i'm going to
have to smudge this [ __ ] with sage
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
it really doesn't
like i said dude listen to this the
other day
i literally you guys i literally
recorded
a test on this microphone because
remember when we did the side tracks on
wednesday night and everybody said why
the [ __ ] do you guys sound like you're
underwater
i don't know but so i was gonna record
something on thursday
so i very deliberately i you know i
tried to put the settings back to where
they were
i did a test on thursday like a
recording and it sounded
beautiful literally 10 minutes later
i recorded like an hour long video or
like a 40 minute long video
i listened to it back and it sounded
like ass damn
and i had not touched anything in the
interim nothing we got to replace that
laptop
or this microphone or something i don't
know i don't know what's going on i
think it is too because you know what i
did
like because today i had to record some
more [ __ ] so i went in there i went into
the settings
and i went in there and i had to disable
what i did was i just disabled the
microphone array
on the laptop just all together i put
this microphone as the only microphone
hopefully that would help i don't really
know
but we'll see how it goes i just can't
understand how that happened because
i literally did a microphone test and it
sounded awesome
and then when i record it again like
10-15 minutes later it just sounded like
but i don't and i had to do the whole
thing over again maybe you should close
the chat
yeah i got the chat right here maybe i
should close close the damn chat
and you know you could maybe you can run
the chat off of uh
um yeah you close the chat on that on
that that maybe stretch strong is
drawing too much
well are you gonna oh it crashed again
did it
no it was they it's probably still going
did you did you close that entire window
back there
well no big i'm telling you like nothing
happens nothing happens
when i when i click um nothing happens
so
i'm just i'm just telling you guys
freezes go ahead and
tell me if freeze is in the comments
section so
yeah i don't i don't really have it's
good here
but i i can't see the chat i can't see
we're not moving it's
you know it's freaking me out which i
can see the chat which means that well
you're just